PROFESSOR: Another way to talk
about congruence and remainder
arithmetic is to work
strictly with remainders,
which makes things a little
simpler because you don't have
to worry about the fact that
the product of two remainders
may, for example, be too
big to be a remainder.
To knock it back
in range, you have
to take the remainder again.
And that's what
this abstract idea
of the ring of integers
modulo n, the ring Z sub n,
captures in a quite elegant way.
So it's going to allow us to
talk strictly about equality
instead of congruence.
And let's remind ourselves that
the basic idea behind working
with a remainder arithmetic
was that every time we
got a number that was too
big to be a remainder,
we just hit it with
the remainder operation
again to bring it back in range.
And so the operations in
Zn work exactly that way.
The elements of Zn
are the remainders.
That is, the numbers from
0, including 0, up to n,
but not including n.
So there are n of them from
0, 1, up through n minus 1.
And the definitions of
the operations in Zn
are given right here.
Addition just
means take this sum
but then take the
remainder immediately,
just in case it's too big.
And likewise, the product in
Zn is simply multiply them
and take the remainder.
This isn't really a
very dramatic idea,
but it turns out to pay off
in making some things just
a little bit easier
to say, because we're
talking about equality
instead of congruence.
So this package together,
this mathematical structure
consisting of the integers
in this interval--
remember this notation,
square bracket
means inclusive and round
parenthesis means exclusive.
So this includes zero,
it doesn't include n.
The integers in that
interval, under the operations
of plus and times modulo
Zn, as defined here,
is called the ring
of integers Zn.
So it's got two
operations and a bunch
of things that are operated on.
Now I guess it's
worth highlighting.
That's what Zn is,
the ring of integers.
Mod n, or modulo n.
Now, arithmetic in Zn is really
just arithmetic-- congruence
arithmetic, except that
it's equality now instead
of congruence.
So we can say, for example,
in Z7 that 3 plus 6
is literally equal to 2
because, well, 3 plus 6 is 9,
the remainder on
division by 7 is 2,
and we go directly
to the two in Zn,
suppressing the mention of
taking remainders and not even
really having to think
about it, which is what's
helpful about working with Zn.
Likewise, 9 times 8 is
literally equal to 6 in Z11.
So what's the connection between
the set of all the integers
and the integers mod n?
And we can state this
abstractly in the following way.
Let's just, for convenience,
abbreviate the remainder of k
on division by n as R of k.
So n is fixed.
And what's the connection
between Z and Zn?
Well, it's fairly simple.
If you take the
remainder of i plus j,
that's literally equal
to taking the sum
of the remainders in Zn.
Once you've taken
the remainders,
you're in the range of
numbers that Zn works with.
And this sum, then, keeps
you in on the Zn side.
Likewise, if you
take the remainder
of a product of real
integers, that's
literally equal to the product
of the remainders in Zn.
This operation, by the
way, this connection
between mathematical
structures, the structure
of the integers
under plus and times
and Zn under plus and times,
is called a homomorphism.
R, in this case, is defining
a homomorphism from Z to Zn.
That's a basic
concept in algebra
that you'll learn
more about if you
take some courses in algebra,
but I'm just mentioning it
for cultural reasons.
We're not going to
exploit it any further,
or look further into this idea.
OK.
What's the connection
between equivalence mod
n, or congruence mod n, and Zn?
Well, it's fairly simple.
In Zn, we convert
congruences into equalities.
So i is congruent to j mod
n if and only if r of i
is equal to r of j in Zn.
And this is just a
rephrasing of the fact
that two numbers
are congruent if
and only if they have
the same remainder.
Now once you've got this
self-contained system Zn,
you can start talking
about algebraic rules
that it satisfies.
And now, they hold with equality
and they're pretty familiar.
So let's look at some of
the rules for addition,
for example, that
hold true in Zn.
First of all, addition
is associative.
i plus j plus k is
i plus j plus k.
We have an identity
element, literally zero.
Zero plus any i is i.
We have a minus operation, an
inverse operation, with respect
to addition, which is that--
how do I get back some slides?
Excuse me.
OK, let's keep going.
I have an inverse operation,
which is that for every i,
there's an element
called minus i.
It's additive inverse such
that if you add i and minus i,
you get zero.
And finally,
commutativity, which
is that i plus j is
the same as j plus i.
You don't really need
to memorize these names,
but you will probably
hear them a lot
in various other contexts, and
especially in algebra courses,
but even in terms of arithmetic.
These are some of the basic
rules that addition satisfies.
And in fact,
multiplication satisfies
pretty much the same rules.
Multiplication is
likewise associative.
There's an identity for
multiplication called 1.
1 times i is i.
Multiplication is
also commutative.
The one obvious omission
here is inverses.
You can't count on there
being inverses in Zn.
And finally,
there's an operation
that connects addition
and multiplication called
distributivity.
Namely, i times j
plus k is ij plus ik,
as you well know from
ordinary arithmetic.
And this rule works fine for
remainders and working in Zn.
As I said, the one thing
we have to watch out
for, it shouldn't
be a surprise, is we
know that you can't cancel with
respect to congruence mod n.
And that's reflected in the fact
that you can't cancel in Zn.
Namely, in Z12, for example, 3
times 2 is equal to 2 times 8.
Again, 3 times 2 is
6, 2 times 8 is 16,
you immediately take the
remainder to get back to 6.
In Z12, these two
things are equal.
But if you tried to cancel the
2, you'd conclude that 3 was 8,
and neither 3-- 3 and
8 are different numbers
in the range from 0 to 12,
and they're different in Z12.
So you can't cancel 2.
OK.
Now the rules that we
already figured out
for when you can
cancel in congruence
translate directly over to
when you can cancel in Zn.
And now there's a
standard abbreviation
that's useful to use here.
If I write Zn*, what I mean
is the elements in Zn that are
relatively prime to n.
The elements whose
GCD with n is 1.
So what we have is the following
equivalent formulations of Zn*,
which correspond to the facts
we've already figured out about
congruence.
Namely, an integer i in the
range from 0 to n is in Zn*
if and only if the
GCD of i and n is 1,
or i is cancelable in Zn,
or i has an inverse in Zn.
All of these three
things are equivalent.
They give you the sense that
Zn* is a kind of robust subset
of Zn that you'd want
to be thinking about.
And in fact, it's very valuable
to be paying attention to.
What else do we know about Zn*?
Well, the definition of
phi of n was the number
of integers in the
interval from 0
to n that are
relatively prime to n.
Of course, that's
exactly the size of Zn*.
So phi of n is simply the size
of that collection of elements.
Not surprising.
They were defined that way.
So now I can restate
Euler's Theorem
in a slightly convenient way.
Instead of mentioning
congruence,
we can just talk about equality.
Euler's Theorem says that if you
raise a number k to the power
phi of n, it's literally
equal to 1 in Zn,
at least for those k's that
are relatively prime to n.
That is, those k's
that are in Zn*.
And it's going to turn out that
the proof of Euler's Theorem
is actually pretty easy.
It just follows in
a couple of steps
from a couple of
simple observations.
So let's start on those.
So the first remark is that if I
have any subset, S, of elements
in Zn-- I don't care whether
they are relatively prime to n
or not-- if I multiply
each of them by k,
this notation for
k times S means
that I'm taking the set of
elements that are of the form
k times an element of S
over all the elements of S.
So kS, which is this
set of multiples
of k-- multiples of
elements of S by k,
has exactly the same size as S.
Now, why is that?
Well, this of course is only
true for k that are cancelable.
But the Lemma is, no matter
what subset you take of Zn,
if you multiplied every
one of them by an element
that's cancelable in Zn*, you
get a set of the same size.
And that's clear because how
could ks1 and ks2 be equal?
Well, only if s1
and s2 were equal.
Or another way to
say it is that if you
had different elements
in S, s1 not equal to s2,
when you multiply
them by k, you have
to get different elements of
ks, because k is cancelable.
OK.
So that's an easy remark.
Holds in general.
Multiply any subset by
a cancelable element,
and you get a new set
that's the same size.
The second remark is that if
you look at numbers i and j that
are in the interval
from 0 to n in Zn,
then if you multiply
the two of them,
then you're going to get an
element in Zn* if and only
if the original two
elements were in Zn*.
Well, let's just look at it in
the left to right direction,
which is the only one we need.
If i and j are
relatively prime to Zn*,
then so is their product,
because if neither i nor j has
a prime factor in common with
n, then their product obviously
doesn't have a factor
in common with n.
And then when you
take remainders,
it's still going to be a
number whose GCD is the same.
And so we have this
remark that if you
multiply two
cancelable elements,
you get a cancelable element.
If you multiply two elements
relatively prime to Zn*,
you get an element of Zn*.
There's about-- every one
of these formulations of Zn*
in terms of GCDs are
cancelable or inverse,
and each of them gives a
separate and straightforward
proof of the fact that
if i and j are in Zn*,
then so is their product.
Now it's worth
mentioning, by the way,
that, in general,
their sum is not.
If you add two elements that
are relatively prime to Zn*,
even if their sum is non-zero,
you will typically get
an element that is no longer
relatively prime to n.
But for multiplication,
it works great,
and that's what matters to us.
OK.
So as a corollary of this is
that I can actually conclude
that, if I choose an
element that's cancelable,
an element in Zn*, if I
take the whole set Zn*,
all those elements that
are relatively prime to n,
and I take multiples of k by
each of them, then, in fact,
I get the same set, Zn*.
And the proof of that is
really straightforward.
Let's think about
it for a minute.
Because what do I know
is that these two sets
are the same size.
kZn* and Zn* are the same size.
As long as k is cancelable, I
don't even care that this was
Zn*.
On the other hand,
if k is in Zn*,
k times Zn* only gives
you elements in Zn*.
So kZn* is a subset
of the left-hand side,
and it's the same size by
the Lemma that says that
multiplying by k
preserves sizes.
So they have to be equal.
So basically what that means
is that if you take all
the elements in Z*, all the
elements relatively prime to n,
and you take another one of
them, pick one out of that set,
and multiply every element
in the set by that element k,
if you had them lined up
in one order beforehand,
when you multiplied by k you
get exactly the same elements
but just reordered.
That is, multiplying by k
has the effect of permuting
the elements of Zn*.
Let's look at an example.
So let's look at Z9.
And we know that phi of 9,
by the previous formula,
is 3 squared minus 3, or 6.
There are going to be 6 elements
from 0 to n that are relatively
prime to 9, and
that comprise Zn*.
So let's look at what they are.
So you can do-- check
the calculation.
But Zn* is exactly the
elements 1, 2, 4, 5, 7, 8.
We know we got them all
because there's only
supposed to be six
of them, and we
can check that those are
all relatively prime to 9.
None of them has 3 as a divisor.
Now what happens, for example,
if I multiply them all by 2?
Two is another good
number-- it's right here--
that's in Zn*.
And multiplying them by
2, well, let's check.
2 times 1 is 2, 2 times
2 is 4, 2 times 4 is 8,
2 times 5 is 1-- because it's 10
with a remainder of 1-- 2 times
7 is 14-- translates
into 5-- 2 times 8
is 16-- [INAUDIBLE]
translates into 7.
And, as claimed, look at this.
Here's 2, 4, 8, 1, 5, 7.
It's the same numbers
as 1, 2, 4, 5, 7, 8,
just in a different order.
Let's do one more example.
Let's try multiplying by 7.
That's another respectable
element over here.
7 times 1 is 7, 7 times 2 is
14, which means it's 5 in Z9.
4 times 7 is 28.
Well, 3 times 7 is 27, so
that leaves a remainder of 1.
And 4 times 7 is 1 in Z9.
Likewise, 5 times 7 is 8, 7
times 7 is 4, and 7 times 8
is 56, which translates to 2.
And sure enough, as claimed, I
see the same numbers, 7, 5, 1,
8, 4, 2, just these
numbers scrambled in order.
They're permuted, which is the
outcome of multiplying by 7.
OK.
So let's go back.
What we've just illustrated is
this fact that we've already
concluded that, if you take
Zn* and you multiply it
by an element k in Zn*, you
get the same set in a different
order.
So Zn* is equal to k times Zn*.
And now we're on the brink
of proving Euler's Theorem.
Because what I want
to do is say, look,
these two sets are the same.
Let's multiply all the
elements on the left
together, and multiply all the
elements on the right together.
Let's take the product
of those elements.
So let's take the product of Zn*
and compare it to the product
of kZn*.
So big pi here is
indicating the product
of all of the elements in
this set, the product of all
of the elements in this set.
Well, let's look at
the set on the right.
This is the product of k
times all the elements in Z*.
Well how many
elements are there?
Phi of n elements in
Z*, by definition.
And let's factor
out all the k's.
So this expression here, the
product of k times each element
in Zn*, is the same as the
product of the elements in Zn*
times k to as many
elements as there were,
namely k to the phi of n.
I'm just factoring k
out of this product.
And there's my k
to the phi of n.
And now look what I got here.
That's pi Zn*,
and that's pi Zn*.
What do I know about
multiplying elements in Zn*?
They're in Zn*.
This product will be some
other element is Zn*.
So will this product.
But what do I know about Zn*?
They're cancelable.
So just looking-- ignoring
the middle term now,
what I'm concluding is that the
product of Zn* is k to the phi
of n times the product of Zn*.
Let's cancel those
cancelable terms.
And I'm done.
I've just figured
out that 1, which
is the result of canceling
the term on the left,
is equal to k to the phi of n.
And we have successfully
proved Euler's Theorem,
which is what we were
aiming for in this segment.